hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley oh baby here we go
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage
the show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and find out if they grow up
classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host h foley coming at you
on a beautiful absolutely beautiful day
here
new york city the east village manhattan
alive and well
gas digital studios in the [ __ ] big
room
for the big guest my co-host is coming
at you right
[ __ ] next to me sipping on a poland
spring
ladies and gentlemen don't forget the
next time you're reaching for a best pal
you make it a kippy this guy tastes
great and he's less filling
give it the [ __ ] up for kevin james ryan
hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in uh real quick little bit of
business as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes
also full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
and also to get the full catalog of all
of our shows as well as every show on
the network
you can sign up for
gasdigitalnetwork.com use promo code ayg
you save a couple of bucks every month
we get to wet our beaks it's a [ __ ]
win-win so yes sir do it and gang we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guests here with us
today
via satellite gas digital technology
78g i don't know what we got but we got
him we could not be more excited
he is an incredibly successful stand-up
comedian actor and voice actor
you've seen him in funny people
workaholics aqua teen hunger force
bob's burgers comedy bang bang the lucas
brothers moving company
adventure time love teachers
those who can't paradise pd he has his
own comedy central presents
you seen him on the tonight show this is
not happening not
safe with nikki glazer drunk history
carson daly
hot ones four appearances on [ __ ]
conan
his specials include loose in chicago
i like his old stuff and whiskey icarus
i don't know if he's garbage or not but
i know he's got a little bit of [ __ ]
cash on him
i'll tell you that right now from that
rap seat give it the [ __ ] up for the one
the only
mr kyle kinnain everybody
[Music]
wow wow you don't you don't know how
much
day rates are and how
this guy was in a honey wagon for 100
bucks a day
oh that's good yeah this guy did a lot
of non-union animation
[Laughter]
kyle thank you so much for doing the
show man good to see you yeah dude
yeah thanks for having me man what's
going on fellas uh not much man we're
chilling um
yeah so what we're gonna do is uh we
wanna hear a little bit about your uh
your past how you grew up and then we'll
launch into some questions
you're you're a midwestern guy right
you're you're illinois
yeah i grew up i mean i i don't know if
it's like a game at the end where we
find out if i'm garbage or not but
probably the backstory is going to give
it away real quick
um absolutely
i grew up in a town called addison
illinois that's about uh 20 miles
outside of chicago
and uh you know i was uh
i still like oh let's see from the start
i don't know i was just uh
i was like a shy kid and then uh i
thought
then like somebody laughed at a joke in
high school i'm like oh being funny
is how you get attention and then that
just made me an [ __ ] because you look
back
at how how often you thought you were
being funny oh yeah
and the percentage of you being funny
versus the percentage of you just being
real obnoxious and louder than anybody
else
it was real lopsided i was like i was
just a real loud jerk for a long time
yeah trying too hard man everybody
everybody experienced that in junior
high
trying way too hard desperate so
desperate just look at me look at me
please please what about uh brothers and
sisters did you grow up in a big family
small
family small family mom and dad are
still kicking still married and i had
one sister she lives down in l.a now but
and we're and she's like close in age
and we were pals so like her group of
friends
group of friend we were all like one big
crew going together
and uh like yeah as you're talking about
like you know knowing the menzingers and
everything we you know it started going
to
go on to see like uh all ages punk rock
shows in the suburbs
yeah and just uh yeah that was like that
was my every weekend once i turned 16
was just going to see bands
and uh and and yeah trying to be in
bands and and
like i just some old footage somebody
just sent me a back in the day where i
clearly had this mike ness fascination
and had hair to have a mic nest
fascination so i was trying to pull out
this whole
social distortion bad boy rockabilly
vibe which is tough when you live with
your parents until you're 26 years old
i don't need anybody it's my mom and dad
yeah you're just singing prison bound
from your car like oh man i'm from the
main streets of
ah [ __ ] my mom's making pot roast
tonight i gotta get home one time
cancel band practice were you so you
were in a band growing up
yeah yeah yeah we i mean nothing nothing
of note it was called the grand marquis
if you did some real dude this
okay here's first pretty good name
that's not a bad name that's pretty good
the grand marquis
that's that's what we thought because me
and the singer and other guitar players
we both drove our parents grand marquis
now we thought it was a cool name but we
wanted to the name so we're going to be
called the grand marquis but we wanted
it to be plural
but we didn't know how to pluralize
it's a french name it's a french word
that ends in s
and so like everybody's like so you're
the grand marquis we're like that's the
grand marquis how do you spell that
we're not real sure
we don't know how we were gonna spell
the name so we never even got around to
making t-shirts or anything
grand marquises check them out this one
what is what is the grand marquis is
that the wagon
no no it's a big boat big mercury boat i
think it's the
ford ford ltd was the ford oh okay
i remember one of those doors would kill
you is that [ __ ] those doors were huge
on those cars
that was a pinky steerer who just hooked
the pinkie
it was light blue as my grandparents so
it was a hand-me-down whip
and just i remember like that was the
one car that had
like enough room to have the
halfway reasonable sex in you know like
when you're you're
like in a ford escort or something in
your crayons or cell or something yeah
there's big ships going up your [ __ ]
or something but this thing was like
there's hotel rooms smaller than this
yeah you know
let me get this car this beautiful plush
seats
it was a it was a beautiful ride i'll
tell you trying to get laid in the
[ __ ] datsun when i was a kid
[ __ ] good luck with that yeah i had a
chevy lumen the same thing it was a big
[ __ ]
because you could put 15 people in that
bag you could have an orgy if you wanted
to it was a big [ __ ] boat
oh [ __ ] chevy lumina they promoted that
one heavy after the movie days of
thunder came out
once again am i garbage yes
days of thunder i love it cole trickle
shout out to [ __ ] tom cruise
cole trickle [ __ ] knew how to [ __ ]
drive a [ __ ] car i'll tell you that
you know what's trashy too is that you
know the one guy that's in that became a
senator the guy that played the guy that
owned nascar
ran nascar i can't think of his name but
he went on to become a senator
i don't know you know what i'm talking
about he um
he was also the bad guy in
uh fletch yes that's am i right yep
that's exactly the background and then
you want to show up on like law and
order or something like that that's
exactly what i'm talking about yeah
that's fine i can't pull it the grand
market right off with a [ __ ] daze of
thunder [ __ ]
reference yeah i love it man
yeah let's get into it let's get into
some [ __ ] ru garbage questions talk
about
uh growing up at the [ __ ] canaan
house so small town
in illinois right near chicago so
basically the suburbs of chicago correct
the the most suburb you can get the most
suburban
like like you it was you know you had
the mcdonald's
and the burger king across the street
from each other and he's like
you divided families by choosing one of
the other there was never a stray
there was never a stray of like let's
get burger king today instead of
mcdonald's
you'd be you'd they'd be you'd have to
sleep in a yard if you said something
what were you were you a mcdonald's
family yeah what was your family
i was at mcdonald's like mcdonald's
because we'd go there and then somebody
took me to burger king once i'm like
look at this place
i know the burgers
we had a taco bell that was a cross
i missed the old taco bells that were
shaped like churches
yeah they were green and the old pizza
huts
the pizza huts yeah had these flat roofs
the taco bells were like like little
iglesias yeah we had a long john silvers
across the street when it still had the
like you had to walk up the dock to get
in the long jump
[Laughter]
and i don't i'd always make the joke
like you'd walk out of long john
silver's like you just got into port
somewhere and using a taco bell
somewhere in south america apparently i
don't remember going through the canal
apparently yeah i was like white trash
epcot centered down yeah
your dad's drunk at the whole thing i'll
tell you man
[ __ ] long john silver is the most
trashiest
of all of all fast food and that was my
fave
our favorite growing up wow wow
i'm gonna i'm gonna you're gonna skip
over white castle or
crystals and go right to long john
silver's you're gonna take down
i don't even know crystals i don't know
crystals is just the the same like uh no
what is it hearties
okay there you are you're right white
cats are more or less the same thing or
or somebody's gonna get pissed off
because people get real defensive about
their garbage food
yes we found out yeah what what
white castle they're the little slide
well you know what white castle
east coast i had them on sunday
you get you get the crave case you get
the cardboard suitcase full of
full of sliders what's all the questions
here i thought we were interviewing you
but
he looked like he was going he was going
away for the month we got defend two
suitcases
walking out of the [ __ ] white castle
yeah we got the crazy handcuffs
he's like he's like he's carrying jewels
like it's a nuclear phone that's [ __ ]
great
yeah it's a nuclear football but
you get the chicken rings you slide them
into the burgers oh yeah man i know all
about it i know the moves
oh that is [ __ ] garbage but anything
open 24 hours becomes your new favorite
fast food
yeah the white castle's here though
cause there's not that many
there's not there's not that many left
so it's like they look wet they look
like old war vets they're like
this you know they're all grizzled and
there's like tumbleweeds of [ __ ]
trash blowing through it's they're tough
to see now
but it's like what you're saying i like
the fact that they kind of like retain
their identity from the 80s like i hate
like what you're saying
i yeah i like the taco bell the way that
look and the pizza huts
and like the wendy's and all the stuff
back in the 80s those places were
[ __ ] awesome
dude pizza hut do you remember when
pizza hut had the salad bar inside
the oiliest ass torpedoes you could
possibly wish for
i love them i get and again my mom would
yell at me
because we go to pizza hut i'm like i
want a sandwich what's wrong with you
work pizza hut
i can't i can't have the thing it's on
the menu
they want me to have it that's really
garbage
ordering a sandwich of pizza hut is
another level of garbage
i remember having waiters at pizza hut
do you guys remember that yes
i remember this guy hit me with the
specials i'm like buddy
make it a stuffed crust and keep it
[ __ ] moving
those old red cups man remember those
old things
a gallon of coca-cola and those things
dude they were so big
you could drop it out of a helicopter
that was the first place do you remember
the white cat first off
it's steamed burgers that's how they
cook it
terrible which is a bit off pudding if
you really want to think about it
everybody working there's just teenagers
with the most open pores you've ever
seen
they're just it's a constant spa facial
they're getting of hamburger grease
the whole place was white tile inside so
they can
hose it off at the end of the night
oh yeah it was like there was no it was
just a
white room with a drain in the middle
yeah
[Laughter]
what's the name of the street that you
grew up on
i grew up on the corner of uh michigan
and diversity
which those are the same names not the
same as those the streets that are in
chicago proper you know
they gotcha you know you go a couple of
suburbs and they just nick the name
yeah well that's pretty classy yeah that
sounds pretty good
i looked it up because somebody told me
i i made the most notable one of the
like on the wikipedia page from my
hometown i'm a notable resident
yeah and uh other people other people
in madison that are notable
[Laughter]
but i think he fell on hard times and
wound up
it's not like he bought like you know a
50-acre estate
no no there's no like oh the old sphinx
place up on the field
it was the long john silvers that's
where he lived
it was the old long john silvers he
moved
then apparently the woman who helped
co-create the beanie babies
oh so she's probably got a little bit of
cash
i think it something says it went south
i think i actually looked into it so i'm
like that's interesting and i think she
got sued out of the beanie babies
uh yeah industry so something dark
happened
everybody everybody thought that those
were going to be worth their weight in
gold
[ __ ] that was the trade did your
family collect them or anything like
that were you a beanie baby baby beanie
babies family
no but no we didn't have any like that
weird trash
collector yeah it's always a bad luck
like some
are like god forbid you say like i'm
into like i'm i like
uh platypuses that's a cute animal and
then everybody just gets you that
gift for the rest of your life
full of platypi and you're like i can't
say no
now i know is my identity we had for
some reason my mother uncle
my mom collected crystal shoes they were
like
porcelain crystal shoes like just one
one shoe and they were tiny oh she still
has them on display in my [ __ ] living
room that's real trash garbage
i i remember like the weird like glass
fig like blowing glass birds and [ __ ]
you could tell us like the practice
stuff that the bong makers were putting
out
yeah so like i don't fault anybody for
the beanie babies thing because like
there's a stock market and it's the same
thing but it's coked out bros doing the
same [ __ ]
buying a bunch of stuff hoping it's
gonna be worth more later on
i'm not judging on that point but um
that okay
more background first job 16 years well
i got fired from uh
31 flavors after two days
because i didn't know how to stop the
soft serve so i just kept going
and i was smelling like grenade what did
i tell you
for like 79
everybody was calling yeah
it was like a second cousin of my moms
who was doing me a favor
and i don't think they needed me as an
employee
i think it was like a gamble like maybe
maybe this maybe this is like a good
rookie bet on this kid
like be real total bomb and i got that
after two days i'm like am i on the
schedule this week like now we couldn't
fit you in and i
i've still called for like five weeks
still trying to get the employees
yeah i worked at a kmart i worked at a
kmart in the same mall that had the
like the bong uh the glass blowers sorry
the bomb makers
it was one of the malls that had uh do
you remember like
independently owned spencer's gifts type
places
a store full of crap and horny stuff
novelties and [ __ ] some weird guy
working there yeah
it was like d and d games and then like
pretty much porno posters like
yeah yeah and just seeing a 12 year old
just standing in front of those posters
with his hand in his pants like how many
times a day
would take out a kid beating off jerking
off
and we had yeah it had like a what was
the the
it had like a dress barn and [ __ ] which
is so insulting
i gotta tell you this is a real trashy
[ __ ] horn
that's a real trashy boy describing i've
never been to a mall that had a k-mart
in it oh yeah
pennies was the other bookend
that's if you had money you went to jc
penney's yeah
yeah i didn't have i didn't have the
kind of clout to get the job at jcpenney
and it had a little caesars in it and so
this is literal garbage my job at the
end of the night was to take the trash
out from the little caesars
and if they had if they made pizzas that
didn't sell they couldn't get them away
at all like oh it's profit loss or
whatever yeah so i would take
the full pizzas my buddy worked with a
little caesars and i would put them on
the
like the cart and then just put the
trash on top of the pizza
oh my god throw the trash out and then
take the free pizzas and put them in my
car
jesus christ dude
that's crazy
they had like the humane rat traps which
were just the glue pads
yeah and i don't know how to main
because like a mice will just get stuck
on there a lot of them
and it was my job to toss those in the
big dumpster and one day i couldn't take
it so i like i got a broomstick and i
was trying to pry
one of the mice off of the glue trap but
i did i just like defer it just became a
bald mouse because it kept rolling
what the [ __ ] that's torture man
i know if i got too far into it where
i'm like i should just kill this thing
at this point but then it was kind of
off of it i got it off so the bald mouse
took off into the stock room
gave
one of my band buddies worked at there's
a different ice uh like there's like
another 31 flavors in that mall
and he was called we always called him
uh john because he's real dumb as [ __ ]
and my mom actually started calling him
that was my mom's nickname for him like
where's slo
john that's the worst when the moms
start using the nicknames that's bad
nickname down and then he's like man
kyle's mom's mean she keeps calling me
like
johnny slow or something like you can't
even get your own nickname without being
dumb
[Laughter]
and he would he would openly rip
whippets with customers waiting to get
ice cream like they would come up to the
cash register and you'd be like hold on
[Laughter]
he's got the wawa on sunday
oh did they just pee in the sink in the
back you'd have to like leave the
station using bathrooms they just kept
peeing in the sink in the back of
ice cream oh holy [ __ ] that's real
garbage i've peed in the sink at my
house before if my girlfriend's in the
in the bathroom i really gotta go
that's right i'll lean up to this to the
kitchen sink and
sneak one in there i get that that's
your home and you're cleaning it this is
a food serving estate
this is a place that the health
department theoretically checks them
theoretically on paper they're supposed
to be there and you know what i'll say
too i don't know about literacy
little caesars now but back in the day
little caesars was legit
[ __ ] good they made awesome pizza
if okay the let's talk about the
hierarchy of this
welcome to the show buddy that was that
was an awkward pause right there
i was like well no let's open up this
dialogue
this one i just had the other day a
little uh papa murphy's
i don't know if you know about this i
don't know it can bake it sounds like a
[ __ ]
it's a way to go it's a future i think
papa mar it's a taken bake they just
kind of assemble it and then you take it
home and you cook it
and it's like a shop like pop-up it's
like that's a place you go and get that
pizza and take it home and cook it
it's a chain yeah it's a chain a pizza
place called papa murphy's but they're
all uncooked so you take it you make it
at home
it's more or less i don't know how they
exist i think they got in a fight
with a contractor or something where
they couldn't get like the oven
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
you want to open pizza in this place you
got to join the union you're like [ __ ]
you guys we're gonna sell them uncooked
we don't need your [ __ ] oven
yeah and then that's how they got out
that's pretty classy though that is
clear
that's better than like take out pizza
because you're doing it yourself it's a
little bit of effort you know what i
mean it's nice because i'm a big
digiorno guy do you like digiorno
sure sure yeah you church it up
why you put your hat on yeah man
what are you oh that's garbage what do
you add on to it that's trash dude
i know that's trash if you're adding if
you're adding toppings to an already
frozen pizza that's trash
what are the add-ons you two are gonna
sit here and tell me
that you're just just so happy to pay an
extra
two bucks for nine black olives when you
could have a goddamn
jar in your cabinet and put as many or
as
few as you want you could have one slice
of black olive if you want
when you're that's trash i'm sorry
olives
if you were doing like prosciutto or
something i'd allow you to maintain
making supremes
what the [ __ ] you can do prosciutto yeah
but you're doing olives
[Laughter]
real high and i was like i wanted to put
hot dogs and macaroni and cheese
but i didn't think it was i'm listening
yeah i wanted something different than
just slice them
so i was i was trying to shred it on a
cheese grater
oh my god and uh
it's hard to tell where the hot dog
stops and your thumb starts oh
i'll tell you that much be careful on
that one i think you might be the only
person in the history of hot dogs to
ever cheese great odds
i'm sorry do you have any grated hot
dogs to go over this spaghetti
i'm sorry did you say this you say
parmesan cheese no grated hot dogs would
be great thank you
it does make sense i get to texturize i
get it i understand it i for sure
understand it i don't know if i could
ever pull the trigger on it but
i get it mac and cheese with hot dogs
prosciutto style hot dog yeah
yeah see some why not have it just with
a different texture
change up i wanted to change into
flavors and working with texture
did you do it like short ways or long
ways did you go for like long curly cues
or short little
nubs i was doing it short ways at first
but just kept breaking the hot dog
and these are veggie car i don't even
eat meat anymore so these were veggie
dogs
cheese grain veggie dogs with mac and
cheese
and from the woman that i love in front
of a woman i love it
still with me she sounds like a [ __ ]
saint yeah that's a keeper right there
let's see you do that [ __ ]
my girlfriend has seen me make stuff and
eat stuff at the apartment
that if she attempted to tell anybody
i'd probably have her killed
things i would not want anybody knowing
ah
wow man criminal all right so we gotta
get going now all the stories are coming
out yeah of course baby so we got the
street what was the name of the grocery
store that your mother went to growing
up what was your local spot
well we had a the two grocery stores
were a dominic's or a jewel
which at some point you would get old
enough
and pluralize jewel and singularize
dominic so dominic's the name dominic
with an apostrophe s
i'm dominic this is my grocery store and
jewel
just like a jewel but for some reason if
whenever you got old it's like i got to
go to jewels
yeah yeah plural live jewels like i
gotta hit up dominic
and like i don't know why it changed but
we were a jewel family it's because
you're garbage
that's a transit trash move right there
a hundred percent we we were saying
and somebody there was a local grocery
store where kevin and i grew up called
gennardi's
okay and you know they'd give you the
plastic bags to leave
and someone had mentioned this either
emailed to us or whatever
but for most of my life we called those
janardi bags
even if it wasn't from that store we
called the plastic bags janardi bags
oh like tissue paper being kleenex
exactly that's good branding on
gennady's
yeah they knew what they were doing
they had a they had one household at
derelicts in bluebell pennsylvania
they had that market cornered a
bunch of fat idiots talking about
plastic bags uh what do you got kid
okay let's see so did you growing up
what the house you grew up in was it a
single family home or an apartment a
townhouse a condo what was it i think
a single family home in a you know a
very suburban neighborhood like ranch
houses and everything it was blue it was
blue collard my dad worked at o'hare
okay airline mechanic my mom was like
stay-at-home mom
and uh yeah it was kind of blue-collar
neighborhood but nothing
uh just like just
normal just like i said the most like
suburban
boring like that it's
i mean i've made the joke before but
it's this weird stagnation of
there's no hardship of like we live in
the country and there's work and there's
horses and things with your pigs we
gotta attend to
and you don't live in the city where
it's like oh man there's all these
different cultures
so much from different you know
different people's families where
they're from it was just like
nah i'm gonna ride our bikes around
we're gonna find some porn in the woods
oh it's still like you know 80 so it's
still like a
forest preserve porn era right you know
you go find an abandoned building break
the windows
you can they the pla the town over
there was that old oval team factory i
was an abandoned home
and everybody's that that they said the
gate one of the gates to hell was in the
basement
and so he'd sneak into the homeless
factory but it looked like
willy wonka's chocolate factory before
they turned the lights on it's like
smoke stacks and a wrought iron gate it
was terrifying
i'm sure and uh my sister was tougher
than me she snuck in there
and we just go by the outside yeah those
suburban [ __ ]
tales of like you know this house is
haunted or like
like you'd walk into the woods and
there'd just be like a burned-out shell
of a house
and you were like what the [ __ ] what
happened here like there's not even a
driveway how the [ __ ] did you get back
here
yeah yeah yeah the house in the middle
of the woods
and i hate sounding like an old man but
it's like it was nice when the internet
wasn't there to squash
mystery you just had to hear [ __ ] in
the eighth grade locker room about how
the fire department flooded the basement
to the ovaltine factory because that's
where the sixth gate to hell is
not the seventh the seventh is over in
lombard everybody
yeah yeah you gotta go to the sixth one
first before you kind of
open the seven one and i'm gonna believe
this kid because he's wearing an iron
maiden t-shirt
in his face i've got eddie on it and i'm
like well this guy looks like he knows
what he's talking about yeah
he's like he's got his head i got a good
head on his shoulders this [ __ ] guy
that reminds me growing up was big for
us because we like skated and [ __ ] and
like you know you're always behind a
shopping center or whatever
was finding the big long uh fluorescent
light bulbs
like in a dumpster or something and
smashing them or hitting each other in
the legs with them
ah man you got one of those you felt
like an american gladiator with one of
those things
so which is yeah just break just
breaking stuff to hear the sound of it
breaking yeah
and i honestly you're boy destruction
yeah yeah i honestly think that like i
know like exactly what you're talking
about but like
it's like yeah today you know not to
sound like an old guy as well but like
having that time and that boredom of the
suburban life
back then there was something charming
about it and when you look back on it
so many good things kind of came out of
it like you know good bands or
you know uh just like good the creative
process which was just good for that
like just having that endless like
remember when a summer felt like it was
[ __ ]
25 years long oh yeah and it was just
nothing
yeah dude i'm 43
and i still will take the whole summer
off from doing stand-up
because i'm like no that's summer break
that's hanging on a summer break
18 but i'm like no i've got to do stuff
during the summer so you know what
time's like
you you're f you can do this whenever
you want you take a vacation whatever
you want you have to wait till
summer but yeah that was all just
skating and biking and yeah it did turn
into
well we're bored let's let's all try and
learn instruments together that was old
yep i think it was like a dave grohl
dave grohl quote or something about like
buy
any instrument you find at a garage sale
and figure it out like
just do that for yourself that's how it
starts
and that's how like we all had bad we
weren't good bands but we all had bands
and then
all your friends have bands you're gonna
all four you guys are gonna put on a
show in a basement
right it's an excuse to have a party
it's gonna be a good time
yeah i i i did like it i i mean as as
ridiculous
as it was it shaped who i became and so
i'm appreciative retroactively i'm
appreciative sure
appreciative yeah that's why we do this
podcast is because of that because
looking back on all that
now did you get this guy yeah did you
ask him about the garage
do you guys have a car yeah
separate yes separate garage oh nice had
two bikes going out of it had a horror
master and a harlow sport stolen out of
it
and that's all right that's a clean
living that's a [ __ ] rich kid you're
driving a horror
that's nice haro sport was bought
off of the penny saver magazines used
and then because it got stolen i got a
couple insurance dollars
from the homeowner like hello yeah
yeah insurance and i saved up and then
put that towards a horror master that
got new
that got stolen and i was on i was
riding a gt pro series
uh used until i saved up and pissed all
my money away when i was 18 on a
s m dirt bike oh yeah yeah
and that's still hanging that's a deep
cut an s m
that's like yeah that's that's like very
that's specialized
yeah i can't believe you're dead yeah
i can't believe your dad let you use the
homeowner's insurance policy
for your [ __ ] bike that's crazy i've
never heard that that's nuts
okay i know i was so pissed and they're
like trying to explain deductibles i'm
like
he's like 13. like what the [ __ ] you're
like sorry our deductibles for 400 bucks
yeah the bike's only two yeah
wow an s m that's something dude my
buddy had one he pulled up we thought he
might as well pulled up in a [ __ ]
cadillac with the s
m we were like what the [ __ ] is it it
was like you only saw those in magazines
or like bike videos you know like
bmx videos yeah damn oh yeah i'd like
like call special order stuff i still
that's all i follow on instagram i don't
follow anything else
on social media it's all old bike
accounts yeah just all these dudes
got like old gt pro performers and pk
rippers that that's all i want to see i
don't know about cars
yeah that was the last trip that was the
last one that i had was a gt pro
performer we got huffy's all growing up
just [ __ ] bikes
and like all my other friends had like
cool bikes [ __ ] harrows diamondbacks
[ __ ] like that
and then finally when i was like turning
16
out of nowhere my dad shows up with a
[ __ ] gt pro performer it was
beautiful it was baby blue
had the [ __ ] neon pink [ __ ]
writing on it and i'm like dude
i want a [ __ ] car i don't want a
[ __ ] bike now we're trying to get
laid here trying to get laid here
[ __ ] 16 you finally [ __ ] dropped
the money
oh man so in that garage was there a
separate
second refrigerator at the canaine house
or no
no but what we have i do have one now at
the house i'm staying at
really yeah that's a classic yeah
up in oregon for the time being um no
but what we had
was uh one appliance
we had like a a green stove and fridge
like straight from whatever era 50s or
something yeah 50s or 60s
yeah like when the house was built and
then i think this
the fridge broke or the stove broke
and so my mom didn't want two different
color things so we just put them both in
the basement so we had a fridge in the
basement
okay also a stove in the basement that
was not connected
it didn't work i i don't know
which i don't remember i think it's
still there
but it's trash wait was the basement
finished and you just had a stove in it
or was it an unfinished basement like
for storage
the basement was finished at one point
but then would get
water in it yeah and so they just let it
go down
yeah we had the same thing we finished
it once and like two weeks later in the
90s it flooded
and it's still there's still a
dehumidifier down there cranking
and you can't get the smell out just
smells musky
three inch watermark and sending with a
shop vac sucking it up
so in that refrigerator downstairs in
the basement would you guys keep like
popsicles and sodas and stuff like that
because we'll count that as a garage
fridge
okay well it wasn't uh right now the
fridge is still down there now because
then my
i moved out in 2003's when i moved to
l.a
at 26 years old by the way
yeah that's when the house was getting
remodeled so i go back and like i
i go back to the same house but it's
like hardwood floors and granite
countertops like like you did a good job
yeah but before it was like
brown shag carpeting and green tiles and
all this stuff and so the
but that old fridge is still kicking
down in the basement but they're not big
drinkers but they always have booze in
the house so it's all
beer nice beer and like weird drinks
that people have brought by
that's what's in the basement a bottle
of kahlua
that's a big garbage thing is the
keeping the second fridge because it's a
garbage mentality it's nice it's great
to have
but the impetus of the thought is i
can't throw out this
yeah i can't this is a expense this is a
appliance i can't throw this i got to
keep it
so you just nobody ever buys a second
fridge it's always
you know barely working or an uncle's
giving it away or you find it
and you just stick it in a spare room so
it's a trash mentality but
it's clean it's gonna be useful and also
like you're in a family you can't take a
30 pack of coors and take up that much
reason
very family fridge you got to put that
in the side fridge
yeah because you've got your
tupperware's full of shredded hot dog
i remember there was definitely times
when like we would you know
be stacking a fridge where you're like
all right well beer has to be cold
the milk's got to stay but this soda can
come out the ketchup can go
the mustard like what's not going to
spoil
no pop was always in a cabinet we always
had pop in a cabinet
call it pop that's a midwest thing
that's trash
well that's why i figured i can get away
with saying it now soda just feels
proper to me you and your fancy
soda over there not a kennedy jesus
christ coastal elites
throwing extra syllables around like
we're all going to live for it
all right um all right so growing up
what was the what was the pop what was
the brand and the hat you kept in the
house or what was your
to i'm going to throw some deep cuts on
oh i love it no because that's one of
the things just so you know people have
been asking because they wanted
they wanted to have you on because they
knew you were a midwest and you would
have the midwest
you're the only yeah you'd have the
midwest items that's what we're cure
like you said crystals
that blew our minds so what was the soda
well chris was in the midwest
crystals is the south but i just knew
that as a counterpoint to white castle
okay all right but all right would pop
now
uh it was usually what was on sale
preferred choice
which ironically enough preferred choice
i think was the in-house brand
of jewel preferred choice the in-house
but like i think my mom always wanted
coke she was a coke person never pepsi
once again
strict lines were drawn yeah yeah lined
in the sand yeah
but if it was on sale rc cola would
float in
the [ __ ] dude let me tell you root
beer
no citrus items no citrus drinks i
myself i love a nice cold squirt take
that sound bite and do what you want
squirt spray got it
ice cold grapefruit wow yellow yellow is
pretty good too
mel okay sure sure the one that would
show up
that nobody ever liked and it would
never come
in a it only came in like the cardboard
tray
would be like it would be like four six
packs yeah in the card
it was it was canfield's is called
canfield's
diet chocolate fudge so there was never
there was never a regular there was only
diet
so something went wrong
where they're like we can only market
this as diet
chocolate fudge soda it was disgusting
and it was in my house
all the time oh my gosh we're used to
getting it
we used to get something similar too and
the reason that we would get that and i
think the reason they sold that
was specifically for diabetics because
that's anybody in my family that had
diabetes
that would be their soda it would be the
diet chocolate fudge soda
i don't know i never thought that was
like it was like in the medical aisle
it was prescription soda get an
orthopedic
a pair of orthopedic shoes and and some
pop it was
it was backed by the reader glasses
get your blood pressure checked and a
six-pack hit the bricks
take two six packs of this and call me
in the morning
yeah i think i never thought of it that
way i just think that's what your trashy
out-of-shape family did i don't know if
that's the
reason no one's making prescription soda
for diabetics that's not a market
it was big in the diabetic community i'm
telling you
no i sugar-free
yeah it's like why can't we get the
regular chocolate fudge soda it's like
they don't make
they only
not like a health nut but definitely not
just eating the trash that
the rest of the family was and you come
in from mowing the lawn or something and
just
crack a room temperature diet chocolate
fudge
my dad would just look he's like drink
[Music]
water water
you're dehydrated you're supposed to
drink like water is gross
anyway this is brown fizzing
disgusting warm chocolate soda dude but
i don't know what it was
every once in a while as a kid when you
were real thirsty a [ __ ]
a warm soda really hit the spot out of a
can i don't know why
it's just trash but it really really did
i remember chugging [ __ ] a couple
diet cokes
that were like 80 degrees in the trunk
of the car and just being like
ah i i
almost uh i almost uh belched myself to
death
i bought a six pack engineer root beer
at the dollar store
like just recently no i
was i was going my cousin to see
son-in-law at the movies
that was a great movie by the way
we went to the dollar store and i was
like awesome
on the shelf which is a dusty six-pack
of root beer and i think i drank them
all during the movie but i was just
oh
[Laughter]
just swiss up longhorn in it man i was
throwing it out i thought i'm gonna die
how do you feel about soda with no ice
would you ever do would you ever you
order
soda
no because i think if i'm getting a
fountain drink that's part of the joy of
it of course thank you that's a classy
answer right sure
the temperature is what is what you like
it's that's the allure
yeah yeah you got to get the bubbles and
the cold yeah
because we think it's garbage when
people order soda with no ice yeah
well i get it because then if you've
ever seen like an ice tray
i like the ice maker
but no one's done people talking dirty
apps at a bar
oh the taps at the bar are disgusting
yeah it's tough
never look at the ketchup dispensers
like never get the pumpkin like
there's certain things i just don't want
to know i know of course
yeah i want to continue like don't tell
me that the little line on the back of
shrimp
is poop i know it is why are you trying
to ruin the trip
i still eat seafood yeah why are you
gonna ruin this [ __ ] like
you could believe the kind of gross
stuff they find in hotel rooms
i live in hotel rooms most of the time
doing i know what i do
yeah i don't want to know yeah yeah yeah
i know what i've done to them
i know it's true i don't need you
telling me what other people like me do
i always get two beds i get one for
sleeping and one for eating
yeah i lay in bed i i
eat in one bed and then i sleep in the
other one
that's tragic oh my god i thought he was
gonna say one for eating one for jerk
and
one for sleeping one for jerking but
eating geez
yeah which one do you slap it in do you
jerk off in the food bed or the sleep
bed
i just go in the bathroom for that like
a gentleman locks the door
no peeky peeky
i still won't masturbate if somebody
knows flying on a plane at the moment
or on a sunday no um all right i got one
here
anyone in your family ever have a
breathalyzer in their car
yeah me you had one really
oh yeah i got i got a dewey about nine
years ago and had to blow and go
in a stick shift in a stick shift pickup
truck too which i thought the whole
point is like
oh you have to have both hands on the
wheel otherwise it's illegal but i'm
trying to drive
drive stick [ __ ] like an octopus yeah
but yeah
steering wheel's doing what it wants to
yeah i got a dewy
2011. damn is that an la thing do they
do that in other
yeah my buddy had one in philly oh
really yeah the interlock it's called
it's expensive too to get one
and you gotta go get it calibrated and
[ __ ] that calibration's the biggest jerk
off
that's dude my buddy said the same thing
he's like this is [ __ ] i gotta go
give this guy 800 bucks
800. you gotta go every
month i think i don't know how many
months i had it for six months or
whatever or like every other week you
had to go get it calibrated
and it was 75 bucks to get it calibrated
each time and the guy it's just an auto
shop it's not the police department
yeah and the guy just didn't even keep a
straight face he's like yeah
i mean i'm not getting any of this money
so yeah it's all going to give me 150
i'm back in a month instead of two weeks
like just
just pay ahead and then there's no such
thing as kell
yeah don't worry about i'd rather take
the [ __ ] six month and county
i'm not [ __ ] paying 75 every two
weeks [ __ ] that because you have to do
it to start it right you have to do it
to start then like intermittently every
15 minutes or 10 minutes or hour and
miles or whatever it would click back on
and you'd have to test again
and i remember this is how just like
[ __ ] you know drunk idiots we were
my buddies like well my buddy got in his
car and then we were all like looking at
it and [ __ ] he's like
well how do you know why doesn't you
know why doesn't the passenger just blow
you know well if the passenger was sober
he would just be driving the car you
idiot you're not gonna
you're not gonna drink and drive with a
sober guy in shotgun you know what i
mean
yeah this seemed like we're doing it bro
i was still partying i gotta get in in
the morning and it wouldn't let me start
yeah same thing dude we would go down to
like atlantic city to party for the
night
and we wouldn't be we'd be sitting in
like a holiday inn parking lot because
we couldn't leave
because vinnie was still drunk i
couldn't argue with it either too like
i'm blowing it and i was like no i'm
like yeah you're right you know yeah
good call there were so many times where
we would like try and then go
be like wow let's go get breakfast or
whatever yeah let's let's let's sleep
this one off a little bit
too many times it locks
on a white ford ranger with a mismatched
camera
that's the ford ranger is the trashiest
of all pickup trucks
i don't care if you're if you've got an
f-150 and it's got bullet holes in it or
three wheels
a ford ranger is trash i loved it and it
was an old parts truck too so it didn't
even have carpeting it just had that
plastic floor that plastics you could
smell the smoke and coffee in there
i did a cross cut a couple of
cross-country tours in that thing was
sleeping in there
holy sleeping in the back like the bed
yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah like screen like screen doors and
stuff in it so
holy [ __ ] i love them let's see you
learn from old punk rock days all those
dudes like get in the van and sleep
yeah they all bootstrapped it yeah why
can't i do the same with comedy you know
yeah you definitely you you definitely
uh you know left a mark on comedy that
way
you were like you definitely though you
would he went to punk rock route
right you know and definitely kind of
opened people's eyes to that yeah i
wasn't getting booked at comedy clubs
and if i was i was eating [ __ ] because i
wasn't doing like a comedy club type act
so i wasn't going to get invited back
i did work at comedy club so i'm like
well just do whatever show you got in
your town
you know i'll be driving through you got
a show i'll do that show and then the
next night i'll drive to the next town
and do the next shows
i might be late dependent on the blow
and go but i'll [ __ ] be there i'll
tell you that
you might have to have the feature run a
little bit
i had that for one of the tours that's
awesome
time depending yeah thank god i got a
sleeping bag in the back
because this isn't going anyone sleep
this one off
all right what do you got foley uh what
do i got so we're talking about sleeping
this is kind of a new one i thought
about this
the other night how do you uh how many
pillows do you need to uh to sleep
comfortably and where do
where were they positioned
this is fun because i want to guess what
is if it's garbage to want a lot of
pillows or
it's very garbage i'll tell you this is
mine which is i think
huh it's garbage to want a lot of
pillows
garbage to have two
two is necessary one is a i can't i
can't psychopath
yeah that's that's axe murder he sleeps
with one pillow
that's you like being in prison yeah if
you could sleep with
hello give me a metal bunk and just a
sweatshirt with my dirty underpants
crammed in it and i'll sleep like that's
yeah even even when i think even when i
was sleeping in the ranger i think i
still have two people
i'm not a [ __ ] gentleman so where do
they go you have two you have two behind
your head
no no i'm a side or stomach sleeper one
under the head with an arm underneath it
and another one for hugging yeah that's
what i'm talking about
you need a hugger i got i go that and
then i need a third one between my legs
i was just going to say between the legs
sometimes the knees get sticky
[Music]
sometimes your knees get sticky and
that's unpleasant
if i fall asleep in my bed you know
so to answer your question to answer
your question
which is the garbage that is the most
garbage depiction right there that's
exactly what i do
and that's the most trashiest yeah
having one to hug and one between your
legs
wow i think treating yourself nicely
that's just self-respect man self-care
dude 2020 you need all the self-care you
can get
ah go ahead all right
do you currently have a bathing suit or
if you went to the pool or the beach
would you wear like basketball shorts
like do you have a bathing suit to wear
well i got a lot of bathing suits okay
because i keep forget
suit and i have and then i forget the
bathing suit because you're never like i
probably won't need this bathing suit
and then i got to buy a cheap one i got
a lot of walmart bathing suits
okay that's fair as long as as long as
you're not there in like you know n1
basketball shorts or something you know
yeah yeah it's tough it's a tough look
for sure
i went the other night no yeah
bathing suit guy definitely i've been a
bathing suit guy
all summer because i went and bought a
bunch at walmart like you're saying
and i can't tell you how many times
whether people have known it or not
or i've been wearing a bathing suit like
shorts and nowhere near a pool
i've been just wearing bathing suits
you're on the subway
the bathing suit style they've upped
their games there's jackets i just need
some tickets i got to have a chapstick
on me at all times
and so i need i can't just do that weird
little flip up thing right uh
yeah are you doing now are you doing the
uh
the catch of the day bathing suit that's
my gag i like if it's got the netting
in the in this one i tell you what you
want to hear something real trashy i get
that one
and then i cut that netting out and it's
perfectly comfortable
you could just not get that yeah dude if
you're doing if you're doing alteration
work on your
walmart bathing suit before you wear it
you're [ __ ] trash
i always like i always do a little if
i'm with a good like a good enough
friend you know i'm like oh you you know
what the catch of the day is like what
is that
you pull the leg up you're like oh it
looks like
we got a shrimp and you just that's what
you got right there
flash some brain on them uh yeah that's
a fun
game and then in the same vein of that
if you know say tomorrow you got to call
tomorrow you got to go to a court or a
wedding or a funeral
do you have a suit that fits that you
can wear tomorrow
uh yes i got a couple of
tailored boots nice but the only reason
i have them
is because uh we're liv when we were
living in la
uh the misses got real uh interested in
magic
okay not the gap the actual art form of
magic there was a place called the magic
castle that you have to dress up
in all right and so we became members of
the magic castle
and so i got a couple of sharp suits
like that's pretty cool that's like a
night out on the town type thing that's
classy that's nice
but going through your face off and
enjoy some illusions no it's like an old
it's like a castle it's like
it's like it's like a classy oh i know
exactly the old school
there's different theaters inside there
there's guys in the corner doing matt
like it's the thing that is so easy to
laugh
at until you go experience it you're
like
i never knew i loved magic this much
yeah
i am okay with feeling like an idiot
because
that's all it is you just feel dumb you
don't know
you know it's not real but they're just
in your face like ta-da
you son of a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
doing
i gotta go buy a suit i gotta show up
i'm looking for you next time
i just spent 300 bucks to be here
oh yeah that's the biggest trick of all
is i poured all my money in this goddamn
magic castle
speaking of college and we have a couple
of standard questions that we want to
make sure we get through uh we're going
to get you out of here in a minute or
two
uh what did you get in your sats having
fun man
i didn't do s i did a cts i didn't take
sats what the hell is that
i always heard about it i never knew
them though i never knew somebody just
mentioned this to us
it was just where i grew up they didn't
you didn't take sats it was regional
s.a.t
yeah i don't know if there's a
corresponding thing but i did i got a 28
on those so i don't know if you want to
research what the scale it was good it
was a good score
i definitely want 28 does not sound good
no it's out of like 32 or something oh
really what'd you get
yeah what'd you say 28 the average act
scores 20.8
that's not too bad and where'd you go to
college
no well that's the thing i was always in
the smart
classes and then i let everybody down
and i went i've been there buddy
i went to a community college for a year
nice
and then i i went to a state school
i think i didn't even make it a semester
at state school
and then i dropped out of that and then
i went to uh
columbia college in chicago not columbia
university
yeah yeah a liberal arts college you
didn't need a
high school diploma to get it oh my god
and i
once around there i think i went to
college for
off and on i got a degree in 2002
okay they made me great because i i was
just taking all these different there's
a liberal arts college and i was like
oh yeah man i'll try an acting class
i'll try an art class i'll do all this
kind of stuff
taking a magic class i honestly
right now i'm sure they have one there
but they're like oh you're gonna
graduate this semester i'm like i don't
want to graduate
pump the brakes dean that's when you've
got to get a real
job like if you're if you're not in
college but you have a college degree
you get a job and that's the end of your
life no man i thought i could just
finagle
a couple classes and some part-time jobs
like yeah
you're getting a bachelor's degree it's
not it's just in like applied studies
it's not even enough
and so i graduated i was like all right
and i was it started comedy at the time
and
that's what i'm like i guess i'll move
to california there you go
so i went to i went to three different
colleges over the course of
seven years
that's [ __ ] trash
that's next level trash
[Laughter]
i could just see you in an interview you
went to three schools in seven
years you majored in needlepoint what
the [ __ ] is this
you should be a doctor on the space
station
uh all right i got one or two more and
then i have i just have a few quick ones
that i want to run through with uh that
are specific midwest so we
because we get like hundreds of [ __ ]
people submitting questions
and somebody submitted a bunch of
midwest ones that i want to get to that
i don't even know what they are so you
might be able to shed some light but one
i want to know
are you a bagel bite guy or a pizza roll
guy
pizza get the [ __ ] wow
really yeah get out of here with your
[ __ ] bougie bagel bites bagel bites
totinos all day
no tinos
it's an italian company they ship them
in
this is not anti-semitic in any way
[Laughter]
i love bagels and uh the jewish people
they're great people
oh i love affirmative i'm gonna have
tina on this one they were around
they're great but my family was a
english muffin pizza household somebody
just sent that
recipe in it's i don't
know why anybody had to write down a
recipe
gotta get the right cheese you couldn't
figure that one out yeah
there's no culinary school involved
english muffin
name sauce and piece of cheese and then
you got those olives in the cabinet from
earlier
you throw those on there come on maybe
one maybe you can
whatever a little section both pieces
whatever you want here's the big
question though
the english muffin brand what was it was
it thomas's
yeah yeah there's always thomas i don't
even think they make anything there's a
there's a couple and they [ __ ] stink
they're like muffins they're trash
thomases are nothing yeah that's a
staunch rule no i only have promises
otherwise
any other pastry was from entenmann's oh
i know that you were royalty the long
danish you never got the long coffee
cake
body love the line dude i didn't
appreciate the danish until i got older
like
when i was like an eight nine ten i
thought that was like adult food yeah it
was like always with coffee i'm like
well i don't [ __ ] give me the donut give
me the
the the cupcake the devil's food cake
something i got older that [ __ ] long
danish
cheese classy with the crumb on top good
night i worked at a donut factory
here this is more tidbit for garbage
i worked out oh you already we the
conclusion's already in kyle just to let
you know
let me just seal the deal all right
we have the guys in the lab working on
the numbers but we're pretty sure
we're pretty sure
i was because i didn't want to work
customer service
when i was in high school and everything
like i hated the idea of running into
other people
from school i always felt bad for the
kids that did work at mcdonald's and
then
people come in look at you you [ __ ]
nerd don't make my food like
how can you call them
yeah yeah it was you know high school
politics but so i went
we had like a large industrial area in
addison
and i just saw that like i would just go
like i'll do what do you want i'm young
and i'm i'll do dumb [ __ ] that is
yeah i'll i'll defy regulations
i don't need no papers no i was working
at this donut fact like like
like like conveyor belts and deep freeze
they would ship it off to grocery stores
and everything
but because it was all like mostly like
uh hispanic people that worked there you
migrant
workers that worked in there and i was
the only white guy and so they thought i
was related to the boss
they all hated me at first but then they
found out i was just a kid
working there and also i would eat the
donuts for lunch because it was all like
anything
like mix messed up by the machine so i
just
every day for lunch i would have all
these like misshapen donuts
and so they thought i was the poorest
white person
and so they would feed me all this
really great homemade like
mexican americans oh it's great but i
felt i'm like you don't have to do this
i'm fine they're like
why are you eating all this garbage i'm
like you have no idea
this is a treasure trove
two weeks ago i was eating little
caesar's pizza under trash
that was had trash juice on it my other
buddy
my other buddy worked at the uh the
willy wonka processing plant
the like the packaging plant yeah he was
like he's there in my band
and so he just would come to band
practice and we just have like
buckets of candy just that's awesome
candy
that's my candy and i'm surprised i have
an original tooth left in my head at
this point
we used to have uh you know pepperidge
farms well peppered farms whenever they
would [ __ ] something up
they had a store that sold irregular
products
so you would get like maybe like the
misshapen milanos and stuff like that
and my mom would go up there like once a
month and just [ __ ] load up
on all these [ __ ] up cookies
oh yeah right we got we actually
dropped a bunch of blue food coloring
the bruised and reduced rack at the
grocery store if i see it parked in the
back
bathrooms like yeah let me go see what
we got here check out the clear track at
the bakery that's [ __ ] clean living
right there
oh yeah man all right kippy hit him with
the midwest
yeah here here's a couple of the midwest
specific ones
um have you ever played pull tabs
what's that i ain't playing my mom still
my mom still goes to bingo she loves
them
she's like that she don't even like the
bingo part of bingo she goes mostly to
play pull tabs
it's like a it's like a lottery ticket
type game i think right
instead of a scratch off it's like has a
little cardboard door
it's all oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we call
them 50 50.
yeah it's like a white trash advent
calendar yeah
yeah we used to call them 50 50s and you
would get them at like fairs and [ __ ]
like that
those were you get you get on a roll of
one of those that was a [ __ ] hot day
funnel cake for everybody yeah oh my god
elephant ears for me and my boys
keep them coming and then
have you ever purchased three two beers
that's not midwest that's utah oh is it
what's two beers
three two three that's uh
like you're saying diabetics with the
diet diet soda
three two beers in utah because they're
super mormon and religious
they would sell alcohol but at a lower
alcohol rate
so 3.2 alcohol for the beers
is the beer that you would buy like if
you go to utah
it's the a lot of the beer not so much
anymore because they're slowly changing
it
but if you got like a case of budweiser
normally i think it's five percent
alcohol
yeah it's 3.2 because what joseph
doesn't want you to get [ __ ] up or
something i don't know it's
but that's more of a utah mormon thing i
know that about the midwest
that's garbage man oh well here it says
three two beer
is so yeah some grocery store and gas
station would sell it
when the liquor stores are closed
because it's technically not considered
ah i guess it's like a way around uh you
know
once the stores for the real booze bags
that are looking for uh
for the party to go on that's a utah
i never knew like where i was at there
was no kind of
like religious control over like you
could buy booze liquor stores were open
you're fine i
always go to liquor store i used to go
to the liquor store to buy my mom's
cigarettes you send me with a note be
like six years old right
oh yeah please sell my son one pack of
winston one hundreds
oh
it was a winston family for a long time
yeah my stepdad
marlboro ultralights she's a marble
ultralight that's that's like an
aristocrat at that point
yeah anything 100 though that's pretty
garbage
smoking especially
seeing your mom with a 100 hanging out
of her mouth
lipstick on the end of it [ __ ] puke
i my that liberal arts college i had
enough money left for one train ticket
from
union station in chicago back out to the
burbs i i figured out the math i had
exactly enough money for that
and i when i was smoking i was up to
about like two packs a day
at one point and uh and i always smoked
like
dorals i smoked generic cigarettes and
they had um
[ __ ] i was they were called like durango
100 it was something
like a menthol 100 and that was the only
fact
yeah i had enough money for that and a
train ticket home and i was just
trying to stop menthol 100s
oh that yeah i was gnarly when i was
smoking [ __ ] jack kerouac that's
[ __ ] hard i was almost pulling butts
out
of the ashtray oh yeah dude you know
you're at a bad point life when you're
doing sig math at the store
that's bad news they only took like two
drags off this thing
yeah holy [ __ ] that's it for me man yeah
kyle kinnain i gotta tell you
100 midwest unadulterated
garbage unfiltered no 3.2 or whatever
this kid's [ __ ] heavy alcohol garbage
oh man but the best kind yeah dude thank
you so much ma'am
yeah buddy thank you so much anything
you want the folks out there to know you
got anything coming up
anything you want to plug put out a new
album
called trampoline in a ditch put that
out a couple
uh maybe about a month ago so that's out
other than that man i hope to do shows
i know i either got to retire or
something something's got to happen
i'm living semi-retired i've been i was
joking about it before all this now i'm
like oh you mean i just do comedy when i
want to and the rest of the time i'm
[ __ ] off with bicycles and rc cars
and [ __ ]
yeah some aspects of it ain't too shabby
i'll tell you that there
there is a nostalgia of having nothing
to do and ain't bad playing with rc cars
jesus christ stop it right now you're
[ __ ] killing yourself
holy [ __ ] rc he drops the custom rc car
yeah i'm just in the back tinkering you
know oh my god
right now the other tab open next to you
guys on my computer is trying to figure
out what guns i can buy in oregon with a
california dragon
this guy's getting oh [ __ ] kippy what do
you got to tell him
uh guys just as always thanks so much
for uh supporting as we got this off the
ground please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes keep us in the top
two hundo
um full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
and if you want to get the full catalog
of our shows and all the shows on the
network
please you can subscribe to gas digital
with promo code ayg
we you save a couple of bucks we make a
couple of bucks the world goes round
baby
yes sir guys thank you so much we love
you and we'll see you next week
yeah peace